(tense music)
- I'm assuming you're Alfred.
- Am I crazy,
or did we finally get to see
Superman in the black suit?
We are gonna break all this down for you
and tell you what this means
for Zack Snyder's version
of "Justice League"
right now on The Ketchup.
During Justice Con, which was
happening at the same time,
but you know, just down the virtual street
from Comic-Con@Home,
a panel centered around Zack Snyder
revealed some pretty interesting details
about his version of "Justice League,"
which is coming to HBO Max next year.
Counting down the days.
And he debuted a never-before-seen clip
that features Henry Cavill's Superman
wearing the black suit
while meeting Alfred,
played by, of course, Jeremy Irons.
A lot of star power in one scene.
- Well, that was fun while it didn't last.
- Now, basically the black suit
dates back to the comics in the '90s,
when a pretty huge deal was
made about the death of Superman
at the hands of Doomsday,
which is also who killed him
in "Batman v Superman: Dawn of justice."
But when he inevitably
returned in the comics,
he initially wore a black
version of his iconic suit,
which has since become a
popular piece of Superman lore.
Also, most of us just look
better in black anyway, right?
So it was thought that when
Superman was resurrected
in "Justice League," we would see it,
which Snyder has said was his
intention from the beginning.
So, in other words, it looks like
we'll be getting more of
Superman's resurrection story.
♪ Hallelujah ♪
Of course his original version
was drastically changed by
new director Joss Whedon
after Snyder left the project -
and for more on that,
check out our past episodes
about the Snyder Cut -
meaning we did not see the black suit
in the version that exists right now,
which is a Rotten 40% on
the Tomatometer, by the way.
- Ride ain't over yet.
- My man!
- The closest we have come to seeing it
was actually in a deleted scene
that came with the "Justice
League" Blu-ray release.
Remember those?
And in it, we see Clark Kent
in the fortress of solitude,
walking past both the black suit
and some Kryptonian space armor.
Can we talk about how dope
that closet was, though?
Funny enough, that scene
could have really helped
Superman's character
arc in "Justice League,"
which is one of the many reasons
fans have demanded to see a Snyder Cut.
- Good. 'Cause I really like being alive.
- Speaking of which, Snyder
also teased on the panel
that he is trying to secure the name
"Zack Snyder's Justice
League" for the film,
but isn't sure if that's legally possible.
Would love your thoughts on that one.
And the clip that was shown
shows off one of his main focuses,
which is restoring the
film's intended aspect ratio,
adding that a lot of
important parts of scenes
were actually cropped out of the frame.
With that, Snyder was sure to be clear
that he most definitely won't be using
any footage that wasn't shot by him.
So in other words,
goodbye to Superman's
CGIed upper lip. RIP.
- I know you.
- All right friends,
it's time for us to kick
it over to you, now.
What are you most excited to see
in Zack Snyder's version
of the "Justice League?"
Please unload all your
thoughts and feelings
in the comments section,
and if you want more
movie and streaming news,
head on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
But all of it doesn't stop there, guys.
Join us on our fan group on Facebook,
because we can chat about the
black suit, the blue suit,
I mean, heck, even the
nonexistent purple suit,
whatever we want, and connect there.
As always, thank you guys
for watching The Ketchup,
I'm Naz Perez, and I'm gonna
go put on my black suit now.
Bathing suit, that is,
but I guess I should buy an
above-the-ground pool first.
Bye.
(upbeat music)